Okay, good morning. So today uh this
morning we are doing the Renaissance.
Specifically we are asking the question
how the Renaissance how did the
Renaissance start? Because the
Renaissance was a re was an intellectual
revolution in uh Europe that would
ultimately change the fate of Europe.
Okay guys, um the Renaissance was a
re-imagining of classical Greece in a
Christian European context. Okay, so
what the Renaissance is going to do is
combine classical Greece with Christian
Europe and it's going to create
modernity. All right. So the ideas
um the values that underpin modernity,
the world we live in today starts with
the Renaissance.
Okay. So the question we are looking at
this morning is how did the Renaissance
start? Okay. And there are lots of very
different theories and what scholars
today believe is it was a perfect storm
of cultural historical economic trends.
Okay. So let's look at the main factors.
The first is the decline of consenapole.
So for um hundreds of years consenapole
was the epicenter of European culture.
It is the here to the Roman GO Roman
legacy. But as the Ottoman Turks start
to encroach on Bisantine territory um a
lot of the scholars a lot of the major
thinkers of bison empire they start to
shift back to Europe and they bring with
them Plato Aristotle okay so that's one
major factor the crusades the crusades
remember we discussed last class it was
a time when Europeans encountered the
Muslim world um at mass and as a result
they absorb a lot of the culture culture
and politics of the Islamic Golden
Age. Then there was a fact that in Italy
you had many different citystates in
competition with each other and we as we
discussed in many classes before when
you have that you have something called
open cooperative competition which leads
to um innovation. Okay. Also, what's
really important for us to remember is
that because these city states were
always at war with each other, everyone
was a participant in history. Remember,
if you are a if you are in an imperial
bureaucracy, if you're a bureaucrat, you
can sort of stand outside of history and
observe history. But if you're a
participant in history, then you are
fighting wars. You're a participant in
politics. Okay? you're always thinking
about the relevance of your theory to
reality. Um, the three major city states
of Italy that will give rise to
Renaissance are Florence, Venice and
Genoa. Venice and Genoa are known for
their slave trade. Okay? So, they're
trading slaves with the Muslim world.
And through this trade they're bringing
back uh the books, the ideas, the values
of the Islamic world into Europe as well
because of this trade and commerce. Um
these three cities states become
extremely wealthy and that allows them
to patronize the
arts. Um so you have the rise of a
merchant elite in Florence. The family
is called the
medi. Okay. Why this is important is um
previous elites were either of the
warrior class or the priest class. If
you're a warrior class, you win your
legitimacy by fighting the battlefield.
If you're a priest, your legitimacy
comes from God or the gods. But if
you're a merchant elite, the question
then is where does your leg legitimacy
come from? And so because of this
question, the medi are forced to
patronize a lot of the arts. they will
patronize uh individuals including uh
Dainci, Raphael, Michelangelo, basically
the major artists of the Renaissance.
Okay. Um at this time from 1305 to 1378
there actually two popes in Europe.
There's a crisis of legitimacy and
authority in the Catholic Church. Uh the
pope moves to Avanon and therefore the
pope doesn't really have authority over
Italy.
You also have um the rise of
universities and monasteries.
Universities and monasteries are places
of theological debate and discussion and
they store the classics and this is
where a lot of new ideas will um come
from. And then uh the last factor uh to
think about is in 1440 around then um a
man named Gutenberg he will invent the
printing press and the printing press
allows for the rapid dissemination of
literacy and knowledge. Okay. So what
scholars believe is um these various
factors will coalesce into the
renaissance and mark an intellectual
revolution in Europe. All right. Now,
the thing that you um uh will remember
about my teaching in this class is I
disagree with scholarship. I think
there's one factor that they're missing
out and it's the main factor in the
creation of the Renaissance. I believe I
will argue to you today that Dante, the
divine comedy, is what ultimately
sparked the Renaissance. without Dante
the Renaissance this revolution would
not have been possible. Okay. So this
class I'm going to present you the
scholarly mainstream argument and then I
will present my argument which is that
Dante is most responsible for the
Renaissance. Okay. Um some a basic fact
that we need to
remember. If you look at all the major
figures of the Renaissance, okay,
including Raphael, Galileo,
um Pocachio, uh Michelangelo, okay, the
person who was born the earliest is
actually Dante. Okay, in
1265. So that is a good clue to suggest
that perhaps it was Dante that sparked
the Renaissance that he's the uh secret
sauce that made the Renaissance
possible. Okay. And throughout this
class I will make you uh this argument.
But first let's go just go over through
the scholarly mainstream argument. Okay.
So um first thing to remember that is
that before the renaissance Europe was
was connected with Africa uh Asia and
the Middle East through these dense
trade networks. As we discussed
previously the three main uh city states
that are involved in global trade are um
Venice, okay, Genanoa and Florence.
Venice and Jonoa are the ones who
benefit the most from this trade because
they are by the coast and they're the
ones that mo that are most strategically
located to benefit from this trade.
Okay. And this trade mainly slave trade
actually uh so Genanoa and Venice will
engage mainly in slave trade. Florence
will not engage in slave trade. It will
engage main in wool. Okay.
Wool. Um so this is Venice and the slave
trade made Venice extremely prosperous.
This is Florence in around the 15th
century. Okay. So um one thing to
remember about Italy at this point is
that it is divided into waring city
states. Okay. And as a result they're
always in competition with each other.
They're always at war with each other.
And as we discussed previously, this
scenario will drive innovation in
Europe. Okay, mainly commercial
innovation. By the by about the year
1000, as we discussed last class, Europe
um is now prosperous and they are
engaging in commercial trade. The
problem is how do you facilitate trade,
right? So, for example, if England has a
lot of cotton and then France has a lot
of um
bananas, what if England doesn't want
bananas? Well, England and France cannot
trade with with each other. So, the only
way to get around this is by creating a
currency that everyone wants and the
currency that everyone wants is gold.
So, in Florence, they create something
called the gold floren, which is the
currency of uh Florence. But because it
is so um prestigious because it's mainly
gold everyone wants it and so the gold
floren becomes the currency of European
trade and the family that most benefits
from uh the status of the floren is the
medi medi family. Okay. So this is
kasumo the basic basically the founding
patriarch of the family. And so what he
will do is he will pull the resources of
rich people in Florence and to create a
bank meaning if you're a merchant you
can borrow from uh this bank and what he
will do is he will set up branches all
throughout Europe in order to facilitate
and underwrite European trade. Okay. And
obviously he gets a cut of all this
trade and as a result the Medachi family
become tremendously wealthy and they
create the Medi dynasty. From this
family four popes will emerge. Okay,
four popes will emerge. They will
eventually take over Floren and create
their own monarchy. As we discussed, if
you're a merchant family, you have a
legitimacy problem. You didn't uh win
the title. you didn't win your wealth on
the battlefield. You don't represent
God. All you all you have is a lot of
money. So in order to legitimize
themselves, they will go on a massive
spending spree in order to make Florence
the cultural capital of Europe. Okay? So
they will first of all fund these
massive agricultural projects. Uh the
most famous church in Florence is called
the Santa Maria de Fore. It's still
there. You guys can still visit it. It's
the fourth largest church in the world.
It's absolutely stunning. Okay, here's
here's another view of the church and
the city of Florence and it's still
there today. If you fly to Florence, you
will still see this picture. Okay, it is
incredibly well preserved. This is what
inside the church looks like. All
right. They will also patronize
um artists. the most famous artists of
this time were patronized by the Medishi
family. So, Michelangelo
um was actually lived with the Med M
Medi family for a while and of course
he's most famous for a painting called
the creation of Adam which we which we
will discuss. Okay, the creation of Adam
is also famous for the statue of David.
All
right. You also have Dainci who is
considered the um archetypal Renaissance
man. If you when you think of the
Renaissance, you think of Dainci. Okay.
Okay. So, uh these are some of his
paintings. He is a remarkable genius. He
is what we call a polymath, which means
that he dabbles or he's interested in
every single field of human knowledge.
the sciences, philosophy, poetry, art,
music, everything. And he takes all
these different disciplines and combines
them into his
art. Okay, this is one of his most
famous paintings, the last supper. And
this painting I will show you is a work
of genius. Okay, so later on we will
actually discuss the last supper, but
first I introduce it to you here. Um
this is the school of Athens by Raphael.
Um one one of the most famous paintings
in the
world. You also have uh Velli
um Donatello
um and again these are um the most
famous artists of the Renaissance and
the Meduchi pigiz every single one of
them. Later on in this class, we'll
actually discuss these paintings. But um
as the medics are patronizing
uh art and culture in Florence, the
printing press is being invented by
Gutenberg in Germany. And the and the
printing press, it marks a revolution
uh of literacy in Europe. Okay, this is
a picture of what a printing shop looks
like.
Okay, so um think about this.
So the printing press first arrives in
Venice in 1469. Uh only 30 years later
there are 417 printing presses in a
city. Think of these as publishing
houses. All
right. Um in the first 50
years there are 20 million volumes of
books that are printed in Europe. So the
printing press is a uh revolution of
literacy and knowledge in Europe that
democratizes knowledge. Everyone now has
access to Plato, Aristotle, the
Bible. And what they're reading are some
of the major thinkers of the
Renaissance. So in in terms of poetry,
there are three major uh poets. There's
Dante, there's Petro and there's
Bokachio. All
right. You also have uh Nicolo Makia who
we still read today. Um his most famous
work is called the prince and the prince
is really one of the first political
treatises in the world. The question
then is how do you best govern um a
state? And today we we remember the
prince for its strategy for its almost
amoral strategy on how to rule a state.
What we need to remember is that Mcaveli
himself during this time he was a
startant democrat. He believed that the
people needed um to have a say over the
fears of Florence and as a result he
came into contact with the Meduchese who
tortured him. Okay. But he wrote the
prince in order to raise awareness about
politics. He believed that if we are to
have a well functioning republic then
everyone needs to understand how
politics works.
Okay. And then you also have from
Florence uh Galileo who uh we will
discuss u next week. He is the father of
science. Okay. So these are the major
thinkers of the renaissance. um the
philosophy, the value system that
underpins all this artistic production
is the idea of humanism. Okay, so what
is humanism and how is it different from
um Christianity? Okay, so these are the
three major differences guys. Okay, so
let's let's look at them. If you're a
Christian, the Catholic Church for the
longest time struggled with what is the
nature? What is the idea of
God?
Okay. And humanists concern themselves
with what is the story of humans. Okay?
Do you guys understand? This is the
major
revolution in the intellect uh brought
on by the Renaissance. a transition from
a focus on ideas to a focus on
stories. Second major difference is
Christians always ask how do I save my
soul? How do I ensure that I go to
heaven? But humanists ask how do I
flourish? How do I make the most out of
my talents? How do I have the best
possible life on earth? Okay, so the
Greek word is
udimonia. All right. So, humanism is
actually a return to the values and
belief systems of classical Greece. Now,
last major difference is um Christians
always ask how can we best serve God?
How can we best obey God? But humanists
ask how do we achieve goodness? How do
we make the world we live in today
beautiful and truthful? Okay. So these
are the three major differences that
separate Christians from humanists. And
what this will and what humanism will
represent is a radical re rein reintor
sorry
reorientation
of focus
from the afterworld into the here and
now. Okay. Christians care about what
happens in heaven. Humanists care about
what happens today. How do we make the
most out of today? How do we make the
world a better place? Okay, does that
make sense to you guys? All right. So,
having said that,
let's understand concretely how this
transition happened. It happened mainly
through art. Okay. So the main
transition transition uh to emphasize is
a transition from a focus on ideas to a
focus on stories. So what do I mean by
that? Okay, let's look at some classical
Greek sculptures. If you look at some
Greek sculptures, the thing that stands
out is the motion, the tension, the
emotion in the sculptures, right?
There's a story being told. You can
almost feel that this person is alive
and thinking. All right? You can almost
go into this person's character. It's a
story. This sculpture is actually even
more obvious. Right? Within the
sculpture, there's a story taking place.
It's almost like you're watching a
movie. And what your mind does when it's
looking at the sculpture, when it is in
conversation with the sculpture, it is
imagining what happens before and after.
You are making the sculpture alive with
your
imagination. Okay. So that's classical
Greece. By the time we hit medieval
Christianity, the very concept of art
changes. It becomes more of an idea.
Okay. So this is this is from the Carol
Legian Renaissance. Okay. So, basically
the beginning of the Holy Roman Empire.
And as you can
see, the artwork, it's much more
static. Okay. There's not really a story
here. What's being conveyed to you is an
idea. You don't really have to imagine
what's going on because there's really
no space for you to imagine what's going
on. Okay.
So the main artwork during the medieval
uh Christian period are stained glass
windows. So you go inside a church and
you see pictures on the windows and what
these are are almost like visual aids.
So when the priest is talking about the
stories of the Bible, he's using these
um pictures to illustrate his point
because remember at this point most
people are illiterate because of these
stained glass windows. The effect that
is created um in the observer is
blinding and awesome. Remember these are
windows and they're high up in the
church. So the light is coming through.
It makes the pictures wholly illuminated
with light. It's awesome. You're forced
to send back, but it's also blinding.
Blinding just means that it's hard for
you to imagine what's going on. The
purpose of these um of this artwork is
to make you submit before the power of
God for you to understand the
awesomeness of God. Okay? Does that make
sense? You're not here to participate.
You're here to
submit. All right. So, as you can see,
this is a church. You can see how the
light comes in and it blinds you, right?
And it's hard for you to really
participate in the artwork. So, this is
the idea of medieval Christianity. The
idea that you through artwork you are
trying to represent the
eternity, the awesomeness, the mystery
that is God. All
right. By the time we hit the
Renaissance, the attitude is completely
different. Okay. This is Da Vinci's The
Last Supper. And from blinding and
awesome, we go to compelling and
curious. What this means is compelling
means that you are drawn into the
picture. All right? Why? Because of
death. Okay? Meaning the picture moves
backwards and it moves
forwards. And because of this motion,
you are drawn into the picture. Look at
this table, right? Look at this table.
It's not a complete table. It's too much
too small for 13 people to eat. It's
much too thin. Right? So what your eye
believes is this table is expanding
outwards and so you are part of this
picture. Does that make sense? Okay. And
also it's curious because clearly within
this picture there's a lot of tension.
You see how these different groups are
in discussion. Okay? And they're all
focused on Jesus. So this is the picture
the artwork of the last supper. In the
last supper which appears in the
Bible Jesus reveals that someone has
betrayed them. There's someone uh his
name is Judas Escarid. He has betrayed
them to and um the next day Jesus will
be arrested and he will be crucified.
And once Jesus announces this, everyone
um becomes anxious. Is it me? Is it me?
Am I the betrayer? Okay, there's a lot
of tension in this uh picture. And as
you can see, it's a radical
departure. This very painting is a
radical departure from medieval
Christian art. If you look at previous
medieval Christian art, okay, below, um
first of all, it's much more static.
It's much more organized. There's not
that much tension in the picture. And
what's most important is the idea of
holiness. You see this hollow
surrounding each person in the picture,
right? It shows you that these are
divine figures. What le Leono Dvanchi
has done which is very important is he's
taking really he's really taken out of
the hum he's really taken out the
humanity in the picture. There are no
hallows. What's left is the humanity.
Okay. These are first and foremost
humans not divine
figures. Okay. So this is another
picture previously. So there's much more
detail but as you again as you can see
not as much tension, not as much uh
drama as in the vin da Vinci. All right.
And this is the most recent. Okay. This
is the most recent. Now in uh this uh
artwork, Judas Escarid stands out from
the rest and so that signals him as the
betrayer. But
in Da Vinci's work, it's not obvious who
is the betrayer. Everyone is
um afraid that he or she is the
betrayer. Okay? And then this and what
this does is it forces you to
investigate. It forces you the observer
to observe the details in in order to
figure out who is
who. All
right. What's amazing about this picture
is the focus on human anatomy, facial
expressions, right? You see the tensions
in the neck, you see the hand gestures.
So what um Da Vinci believed is that the
hands the hand motions they are a window
into the soul of a person. Okay. You
want to understand how a person thinks
you see how he or she uses the hands.
Okay. And you can see how the hands are
all in different motions which signifies
different personalities, different
thoughts inside that person. And again
you're forced to investigate. All right.
You can see the anxiety, the stress, the
drama in each of the faces. Da Vinci was
first and foremost an astute observer of
emotions. Okay? How emotions are
expressed through the face, through body
tension, through breathing, through the
eyes.
Um the man who is who will ultimately
responsible for the betrayal is Judas
Escarat and you can see how Dante
subliminally sorry sub with subtlety
emphasizes his betrayal right okay so
you can see how he's darker than the
other individuals so he's turning away
from the light he's betrayed God by
turning away from the light okay also
um in his hand he's
clutching some civil coins. Okay? And
you can see his neck. His neck is being
empas emphasized. Why? Because all the
tension in his neck. Okay? He can't
breathe. Everyone else is anxious.
You're talking. But he cannot bring
himself to talk. So all the tension is
captured in his neck. Okay. All right.
So you see all the subtlety here. Right.
Okay, something really fun about um the
the Last Supper is it becomes the basis
for a very famous book called the Da
Vinci Code. And then and the Da Vinci
Code is a very popular book, no
scholarship, it's just made for
entertainment. What it argues is that
Jesus did not die um um sorry Jesus died
but before he died he married his lover
who is Mary uh Mad Mageline. Okay. And
so this picture becomes one of the
sources for the book. So um previously
scholars have believed that this person
is one of the apostles but when you look
at him okay it turns out she's it's
almost a she right okay and if you look
at how Jesus and this person is
stationed it creates an M shape right an
M can mean but it stands for their
closeness together so Um people
speculate that these two are married and
by doing this what Dante is really
emphasizing is the humanity of Jesus.
Jesus is first and foremost a human.
Okay. So this is this is interesting
guys. Okay. Scholars don't really agree
with this analysis but it becomes the
basis of the Da Vinci Code which is a
really fun book. All right. Something
that um scholars do believe is the
mathematics. So if you look at where the
hands and the bread are and you map it
onto a music sheet, you can actually
play the music. Okay? It's designed to
be musical. Also, look at the
configuration. It's a 3 three one 33
configuration. Okay? It turns out if you
look at the Bible and you look for the
passage
33133 you get this quotation in
Lamentations, okay, in the Bible it
says, "For no one is cast off by the
Lord forever. Though he brings grief, he
will show compassion, so great is his
unfailing love. For he does not
willingly bring affliction or grief to
anyone." And so the idea here is that
God will always love you. God is
love. God is incapable of hating you.
Okay? He will always find a way to
forgive you. And if you remember from
last semester, this is the very idea of
the divine comedy. Okay? Leonardo da
Vinci is getting this idea from Dante.
And this idea is the backbone of the
last supper. Jesus knows he's been
betrayed by Judas Escariat. But look at
him. Okay, let's go back and look at
him. He's calm. He's reassured. He's
already forgiven Judas
Escariat. All right, there's no hatred
in him. There's no anger. The anger and
the hatred um is everyone else. All
right, so that's the last supper. And as
you can see, it is heavily influenced by
uh Dante. All right. This is the most
famous painting in the world, the Mona
Lisa. Um, it has captured the
imagination of millions of people.
Millions of people every year will go to
France, the Lou to stand in line just so
they can spend 10 seconds to look at
this picture.
Okay. What makes this picture remarkable
is it's secretly
alive. When you Donnie spent 16 years
crafting this in a way that by just
talking with it by moving around in
conversation with it, it becomes alive.
So when you just look at it directly,
Mona Lisa isn't really doing anything.
She's just smiling. Sorry. So this she's
she's she's neutral in her expression,
right? But if you turn away from her,
what happens is this. What happens is
she starts off a smile.
Okay. She starts have a smile. So your
eyes play tricks on you. When you move
away from the picture, what happens is
your prefer perfume revision still picks
up the picture but the expression is
different. Okay. So this is the central
version. We just look at her directly.
But as you move further away from her,
she
smiles. Okay. So what what is this
saying? What this is saying is the art
is alive if you engage with it. Okay?
Art is not meant to be blinding and
awesome. It's meant to be here and now.
Only if you participate in the art does
it become alive. Only when it becomes
alive does it it does it achieve its
true meaning. Okay. So this is the Mona
Lisa. All right. Let's look at the
school of Athens by Raphael. Um the the
actual name for this painting is
actually not school of Athens. It's
actually called philosophy. And the
reason why is it was commissioned by
Pope Julius II of the
Vatican in order to decorate his papal
apartments. So if you go inside his
apartment paper apartments today, there
are four
major fresco paintings. The first is
called philosophy and then right beside
philosophy is called religion. Okay. So
religion and philosophy balance each
other out. They are dependent on each
other. And then across the wall are two
more paintings. Poetry and law. All
right. So that's the very ideal of um
the Renaissance. Open-mindedness
exploration and holistic learning. All
right. So let's look at this painting.
First of all, at the very center are two
figures, Plato and Aristotle. How do we
know? Because you're holding two books.
This is a Timus by Plato where he
discusses um the realm of the forms.
Remember before in class we discussed
Platonic philosophy, right? And how um
Plato conceptualizes heaven. God is a
form of the good and then from the good
will will will emanate um concepts truth
beauty justice which will then give rise
to perfect forms okay and so this is um
argued in his book Timus Aristotle his
most famous book is called ethics how to
lead a good life what's amazing about
this picture is you can see that these
two are having a debate so uh first
thing is Plato is pointing upwards Okay,
he's what he's saying is the real world
what matters is heaven and what
Aristotle is saying no what matters is
down here on earth. Okay, Aristotle is
concerned about
um earthly matters. Also look at their
uh colors. So Plato is wearing white and
red. White symbolizes air. Red
symbolizes fire. Right? These are
spiritual colors. But Aristotle is
wearing blue which signifies water. And
then he's also wearing brown which
signifies the earth.
Okay. So they're having this debate and
this debate is as we discussed
previously it is what underpins the
debate within western philosophy even
today.
Okay. Now, what's amazing is that as the
two are walking, all right, they're
splitting the world into two, right?
There are there are those philosophers
who support Aristotle and they focus on
earthly matters and then there are
people who support Plato who focus on
spiritual matters on discovering the
secrets of the
universe. All right. Aristotle is
concerned about um everyday science on
uncovering the secrets of a
reality. Okay, so they're split into two
and as you can see there is depth to
this painting. Okay, there's a sky to
the back. There are these arches and so
it's extending forward and so we're
being drawn into the picture. That's the
power of depth and perception.
Um this is Pythagoras. Uh you will know
him from from Py Pythagoras uh theorem.
But he's first and foremost a
spiritualist. He's concerned about
mysticism. He's concerned about um God.
Uh this is Uklid, okay? Who is the one
of the inventors of
geometry, right? And here he's focused
on using science, using logic, using
deduction to teach his
students. You also have in the picture
many different personalities. You have
Zorastaster who is the founder of
Zoroastronism. Okay, the religion of
Persia. You have Tammy who uh
investigated how uh the planets move.
All right. And as you can see uh
Zoraster, can you see this picture
clearly? Okay. This is more clear.
Zoroaster is concerned with the heavens,
with spiritual matters. Tommy is
concerned with the earth, with all
reality. All right? So, this is Raf
acknowledging that there are two
different realities. There's the
material reality, but then there's also
a spiritual reality, and they're both
important. All right? Now, what's
amazing here is that Raphael, this is
Raphael, actually. This is a
self-portrait of Raphael. He will
actually engage
in the conversation he will listen in.
He will insert himself in the painting.
Okay. Now remember that Christianity
focuses on the idea of humility on self-
negation or removing himself from the
world. But Raphael is reinserting
himself into the world and celebrating
his curiosity, celebrating his
humanity. Okay. And where does he get
this idea from? From Dante, right?
Because Dante makes himself the hero of
the divine comedy. He makes himself the
focus of the divine
comedy. And to go back to the
conversation between Plato and
Aristotle, look at this. Okay, this is a
visual repres representation of the
divine comedy because remember in the
divine comedy, Virgil and Dante are
engaged in a vigorous debate about the
nature of love, of the nature of sin,
right? Okay. So, this is representing
the divine comedy. The structure is the
same as divine comedy. They're al also
as they walk from purgatory uh from from
infernal to purgatory they're also
talking to other historical figures as
well right so this is directly inspired
by
Dante does it make sense to you guys
okay so this is Raphael okay so not only
does Raphael insert himself into the
picture he also inserts his friend
Michelangelo. Okay, this is
Michelangelo. Michelangelo is known for
being reclusive. He's known for not
enjoying the company of others. And
Michelangelo here is conflated with
another historical figure, a philosopher
named Heracitis, who is also known for
not enjoying the company of of others.
Okay. So, this picture just shows you
the immense diversity of human thought
and human personality. It's a sub
celebration of what it means to be
human. Okay. So these paintings leave us
with a fundamental question. All right.
We can now see the radical differences
between Christian art and Renaissance
art. So now the question then
is how did Dante spark the confident
self-exloration and triumphant
self-expression of the Renaissance? If
you look at the art, it is confident. uh
it is triumphant. Okay, it's celebrating
what it means to be human. And what I
will show you now is what he will do is
he will re-imagine our relationship with
God which is a fundamental question of
Europe at this time. Okay. So most
people they're grappling with three
major questions especially
intellectuals. The first question is
what is God? Okay. What is the idea?
What is the nature of God? Second
question is what is the nature of the
relationship between God and humans?
What did God create us? What is our
responsibility to God? Okay. And the
last question is how can we best worship
God? Meaning how can we best ensure our
divinity? How can we best ensure that we
will rise to heaven? All right. So these
are three fundamental questions
underlying Christian society at this
point. All right.
So
um you can take these three questions
and just ask one question really which
is why did Jesus had to die? Why was
Jesus crucified? Okay, this is the
crucification. Okay, why is it that the
son of god, the messiah had to die? And
this idea was first um understood and
discussed by Paul. Okay. And Paul's idea
is
this. God created us and gave us
paradise. Okay, this is Adam and Eve in
the Garden of Eden. But because we were
arrogant, because we were proud, we
wanted to become God. We wanted to eat
that fruit from the tree of knowledge,
which would which would make us like
God. And because we disobeyed God, God
had no choice but to banish us from the
Garden of Eden. Okay? And so why did
Jesus have to come to earth and
sacrifice himself? Because
um without God, we humans can only
commit more and more sin. So to redeem
us and to beg for forgiveness from God,
Jesus came down and sacrificed himself.
Okay? And the sacrifice
um made God relent and forgive us.
And so now we are cleansed of our sins
and now we can begin a new. Right?
That's the idea that Paul is presenting.
Why Jesus is the Messiah and why he had
to kill
himself. The problem though is as
Christianity grows and grows, the
divinity of Christ, the divinity of
Jesus expands. Before he was just a
human who was favored by God, then
became a son of God. But by the time of
a man named Totilian who lived about the
second century, he argued for the holy
trinity which is that God, Jesus and the
Holy Spirit are separate but equal.
Jesus is God. Okay. Now you have a
problem. Now if Jesus is truly God then
why did God have to kill himself? We can
understand if Jesus is the son of God.
Jesus kills himself to um beg for his
father's forgiveness. That makes sense.
All right. But if Jesus is God, then why
did he have to kill himself? Okay, this
this this is now causing a lot of
confusion. So another Christian
theologian by the name of origin um
origin. Okay, so this is the trinity,
right? By the name of origin, he his
explanation is something called the
ransom theory. All right. And the theory
goes like this.
When we were cast off from the garden of
Eden, we became
uh subject to Satan, the devil. We
became slaves to the devil. Remember, it
was it was Satan, the devil who tempted
Eve to eat that food, right? And when
she ate that food, she now swears
allegiance to devil. We are now slaves
to the devil. We are now his property.
So the only way for God to redeem us is
by ransoming ransoming us from Satan by
offering something so valuable that
Satan is willing to make a trade. Right?
So what did God offer? God offered his
life. The trick though is that God
cannot be killed because God is eternal
and perfect. So God tricked Satan. But
what's really important to understand is
this. Before we were slaves to Satan,
but by because God made this trade, we
are now slaves to God. Okay? We are now
slaves to
God. And this very idea will be expanded
and elaborated by Augustine in order to
create the industrial blueprint for the
Catholic Church. All right, this idea of
the ransom theory. All right. So
remember the city of God um Augustine
will say certain things and it's really
important for us to remember what he
said in the city of God. Okay. The main
idea is that we because God ransomed us
we are now his slaves and therefore we
must obey him. We must submit. All
right. So let's go over what he says.
Augustine first thing he says is when
man lives by the standard of man when we
trust ourselves when we use our
imagination when we use our
intuition and not by the standard of
God. The son of God is to submit to him
to obey him. He is like the devil. Okay,
you understand? When we when we use our
imagination, when we use our intuition,
we are like
Satan at our core is the essence of
Satan. It is only by submitting
ourselves to God that we are freed from
the influence of Satan.
Okay? Could anything but pride happen
the start of the evil will? Why did we
disobey God? Why did we eat that fruit?
Because we want to become God. So
there's an arrogance. There's a there's
a pride to us that is the essence of
Satan. Okay? Satan fell from heaven
because of his pride. We if if we just
trust our nature, we will also fall like
Satan.
His was a venial transgression when he
refused to desert his life's companion
even though the refusal to entail
companionship in sin. Eve was tempted by
the
devil. But
Adam ate the fruit because of his love
for Eve. Therefore, love can only
misguide you. Love can only trick you.
Love can only lead you to an evil path.
Okay? Do not trust your intuition. Do
not trust your imagination. But most
importantly, do not trust your love of
others, especially woman.
Okay. The will derives its existence as
a nature from its creation by God. It's
falling away from its true being is due
to its creation out of nothing. Okay.
So, why are we like the why are we like
um the devil? Why can't we trust
ourselves? Because we were created out
of dust. We were created out of nothing.
All right? If we're an angel, we're
created by God and therefore we are
perfect. But because we're created out
of
dust, we are inherently flawed. Okay?
So, we must not trust ourselves. We must
refuse who we are. We must deny who we
are and submit ourselves to the glory
that is God. All
right? We see the two cities were
created by two kinds of love. The
earthly city was created by self-love,
reaching the point of contempt for God.
When we love ourselves, we disobey God.
And that's what explains the world we
live in today. This world is evil
because of our pride, because of our
self-love, because of love for
others. But the heavenly city by the
love of God carried as far as contempt
of self. When we deny who we
are, when we submit fully to God, we can
create a perfect world. We can achieve
heaven. Okay. So again this is the very
idea
um for the Catholic church self-denial
self negation.
Okay now you can think about this and
understand now why the Islamic world
raced ahead of Europe because in Europe
people were paralyzed. People were
afraid to do anything because they
couldn't really trust themselves.
Okay. And but the eventually the
contrast between the Islamic world and
the European Christian world was so
great that even the Catholic Church had
to admit there were problems with the
theology of Augustine. Okay. If you ask
people to deny who they are and to com
submit themselves completely to the
power of the church, it leads to
corruption, stagnation and
inequality. Okay. So there are some
major reforms undertaken by the church
in response to this. Uh one major reform
are the creation of the university
system. So this is the University of
Paris which is chartered in 1200. This
this today is called the Saborn. Okay.
Which is the most famous um university
in France and in Europe basically.
Um one of the most famous professors of
theology at the University of Paris is
Thomas Aquinus. And the Thomas Aquinus,
he's a saint in the Catholic Church. His
importance is he's trying to revise
Augustine for um a Europe in conflict
with Islam. Okay. What what he's really
trying to do is he's trying to take the
pure Platonic world of Augustine and
combine it with Aristotleian science and
logic and reason. He's trying to combine
faith and reason. Okay? And um so he's
trying to update the Catholic Church,
but ultimately he doesn't succeed. And
the reason why is people don't really
understand what he's trying to do. Also,
Augustine has been in power for like
centuries. And so he's really become
part of the culture, the male of Europe.
Okay? He's in the air, you breathe.
That's the power of culture.
The man who will ultimately free Europe
from the grass of Augustine is actually
Dante. And Dante will do so by for
through his poetry. For his poetry, he's
going to reimagine the human
relationship with God. Okay. So in
divine comedy, he will make certain
assertions. The first major assertion is
this. Okay guys, let's read together.
The greatest gift to to the magnimity of
God as he created gave the gift most
suited to his goodness gift that he most
prizes was the freedom of the will.
Okay. So what this is saying is this
when God created us to show his
generosity to show that he's perfect to
show his goodness he gave us the gift
that only God can give us the gift that
he most prizes which is the freedom from
him. Right? You are of God but now you
are free of God. You can do whatever you
want. All right. So that's one of the
central ideas of the divine comedy that
what makes us fundamentally human is
freedom of the will that we can choose
the life we lead. Right? All right. So
let's let's study the divine comedy. Uh
this is this is going to be KTO 7 of
paradise. And in this conto, Beatrice,
remember they're both in heaven.
Beatrice and Dante are engaged in a
intellectual discussion. The question
that they're trying to figure out is why
did Jesus have to kill himself? Okay,
remember before Paul suggested it was to
redeem us from the original sin and then
origin and then uh or um um origin
suggested the idea of the ransom theory.
Okay. Um God had to redeem us. ransom us
from Satan. Now, what's it what what DA
is going to do is he's gonna propose a
new theory and this new theory is going
to
radically reimagine our relationship
with God. Okay. So, so let's look at
this very closely. You say, this is
Beatress talking to Dante. What I've
heard is clear to me, but this is hidden
from me. Why God wield precisely this
pathway for redemption? Okay. Okay. God
wants to save us. But why did God have
to kill
himself? That's a question here. That
makes no sense. Okay? If you're not if
you're non-Christian, it's almost
impossible to explain to someone else
who is not a Christian why Jesus had to
die. Right? It makes no
sense. Brother, this ordinance is buried
from the eyes of everyone whose
intellect has not matured within the
flame of love. Okay? This and Petus is
making this argument which is like you
can only understand this if you truly
love someone. It's only through love
that you can acquire wisdom. You can
acquire empathy and
imagination.
Right? The godly goodness that has
banished every envy from its own self
burns in itself and sparkling so it
shows eternal beauties. Remember last
semester we discussed the nature of God.
God is love itself. There can be no
hate. There can be no envy. There can be
no blemishes within the nature of God.
Okay? All that derives directly from
this goodness is everlasting. Since the
seal of goodness impresses an imprint
that never alters. So God when God
creates, what he creates is also
perfect. Only man's sin man's liberty
makes him unlike the highest good. So
that in him the brightness of his light
is dimmed. Okay. So God is in us. God is
the light that burns in us and allows us
to love others. When we love
others, the bright the brightness burns
brighter. The light burns brighter.
Okay, that's how we celebrate God by
loving
others. We also have the freedom of the
will. Okay, so these are the two things
that God has given us. freedom to
choose, freedom, freedom to lead the
lives we want to to to live and as well
as the power to love and to imagine. But
these things come in conflict when we
choose to do bad. When we choose to
disobey, when we choose to commit sin,
we are turning away from God and
therefore dampening the brightness in
us. Okay? We are purposely stuffing out
the flame in us.
And man cannot regain his dignity unless
where sin left emptiness man fills that
void with just amends for evil pleasure.
Okay. So when you commit sin you must
make amends. You must force yourself.
You must choose to go on the proper path
and make
amends. But for when your nature sins so
totally within its seed then from these
dignities just as from paradise that
nature parted. Okay. Sometimes you could
commit a sin that's so terrible the
light leaves
you. And that's when we disobeyed God in
the Garden of Eden. That sin, the
original sin was so terrible that Adam
doomed all his progeny to
darkness. Okay? And they could never be
regained if you consider carefully by
any way that did not pass across one of
these two fords. Okay? So how do we
forgive? How do we ask for for
forgiveness? Okay, there are two
possibilities. Either through nothing
other than his mercy, God had to pardon
man or of himself, man had to offer
payment for his father. Okay? So there
are two ways for us to get that light
back in us to redeem ourselves in the
eyes of God. The first way is if God
just forgives us. If God says, "I'm
total I'm perfect. I'm total
perfectness. I forgive you because
that's what I do. I forgive you to show
mercy. That's one
possibility. But when he does that, the
problem is we've learned nothing. We
haven't grown. Okay. Another possibility
is if we figure out a way to redeem
ourselves, if we make amends, if we give
God all the gold in the world, okay? But
because our crime was so great, because
we denied the love of God, nothing we
do, nothing, there's nothing we could
give God that would redeem us from our
sin. Okay, that's a conflict here.
That's a paradox. God cannot forgive us
because if he did so, we would not grow
and
learn. And there's nothing we can do to
uh redeem ourselves in the eyes of God
because our crime was so great. So
that's the paradox.
man his limits could not recompensate
for no obedience, no humility he offered
later could have been so deep that it
could match the heights he meant to
reach through disobedience. Men lack the
power to offer satisfaction by himself.
We want to kill God. That was the
original sin. We wanted to eat that
fruit, become God, and then kill God and
become God itself. That's the greatest
crime. So, how can you redeem yourself?
How can you ask for forgiveness if the
crime is to kill God?
Right? For God showed greater generosity
in giving his own self that men might be
able to rise than if he simply pardoned.
Okay? So for thousands of years, God had
to think of a way to redeem us, to
forgive us, but at the same time ensure
we would not do anything like this ever
again. Okay? And the path he chose was
to sacrifice
itself. For every other means fell short
of justice except the way whereby the
son of God humbled himself when he
became incarnate. Okay. So I'm going to
use a metaphor to explain this idea. It
it's a very it's not a great metaphor,
but I think this will illustrate what
Beatric is saying here about God. Let's
just have a daughter named Eve. I have a
f favorite dog named Johnny. I love
Johnny and I love Eve. I love both.
Okay. And I say to Eve, "Johnny is my
favorite
um dog. You're my favorite favorite
daughter. I love you both." Eve, because
she's young and she's stupid, she
decides, I only want my father to love
me. So Eve purposefully kills my dog,
Johnny. All right. Now, what do I do?
I'm Eve's father. If I just say, "Eve,
don't worry about it. You're young. It
was a mistake." Eve is probably going to
go hurt someone else, right? I have to
teach her a lesson.
But if I hit her or I punish her,
then that might suggest to Eve I don't
really love her. It doesn't make sense.
That's a paradox here. That's that's a
conflict. And so what I choose to do
after many weeks of intense thinking is
I choose to punish myself on behalf of
Eve. Okay? I take a bat and I hit myself
or I take a whip and I hit myself and my
hand is bleeding and Eve watches
this and you can see that when Eve sees
this, she has to cry. She has to cry and
feel remorse for what she uh did and she
also cries because she knows I truly
love her. Okay, so that's what Peter is
saying here. God loves us so much that
he's willing to do everything in order
to teach us to be better human beings.
Okay. That's the power of
God. All
right. All right. So, the conversation
continues and this story makes sense,
but it's also going to create a lot of
problems. Okay. One major problem is if
God created
us and God loves
us, why are we making mistakes? Why are
we dying? Why are we in pain? Okay. And
this is what Peter says. You say, I see
that water, see that fire and air and
earth and all that they compose come to
corruption and endure so briefly. Okay.
So in this world, there is death,
there's dying, there's pain, there's
suffering. Why is that? And yet these
two were things created. If what has
been said above is true, then these
things never should be subject to
corruption. If whatever if whatever God
creates is perfect, then things
shouldn't die. Right,
brother? The angels in the pure country
where you are now, these may be said to
be created as they are in all their
being. Okay? Yes, it is true that God
created everything in this world. But
there's a problem. There's a difference.
Whereas the elements that you have
mentioned as well as those things that
are made from them received their form
from accredited
power, the matter they contained had
been created. Just as within the stars
that wheel around them, the power to
give form had been created. The rays and
motion of the holy light draw forth the
soul of every animal and plant from
matter able to take form. Okay. So what
this is saying is this. God did not
create animals and plants. God created
the laws of the universe. He c the atoms
the essence that would give rise to
animals and
plants. And so they're not perfect.
Okay. The laws are perfect. The holy
light is perfect but not the creation
from the holy light. And this creation
was meant to die so that new creations
can come out. Okay? Right? When a animal
uh dies, the atoms break away and then a
new form comes into being. Okay? That's
the law of the universe. So that's
perfect, but not the animals and plants
are perfect.
But your life is breathed forth
immediately by the chief good who so
ammers it of his own self that it
desires him always. Okay. So now the
question then is if animals and plants
aren't
perfect what are humans then
right?
So okay and this is what she says. So
reasoning you can also can deduce your
resurrection you need but remember the
way in which your human flesh was
fashioned when both of the first parents
were created. Okay so this is the trick
you have to remember
this animals and plants are created from
the laws of the universe which God
created. Angels are created by God uh
himself and therefore the angels are
perfect. We humans have a dual nature.
We are both created from the laws of the
universe and we are both created by God
itself. All right? Because when God
created Adam, God created him from out
of dust. Okay? But then what God did was
breathe life into him.
So the essence of God is within Adam and
therefore
us. Our bodies are mortal but our souls
are immortal. Our souls have the essence
of God which is love. The more we love,
the more the light burns in us. And as
light burns in us, it will allow for our
resurrection. Okay?
because the matter will regenerate. The
soul is eternal. Okay. So that's what
Dante is saying here. The best way to
celebrate God is by loving others. When
you love
others, you are activating your
imagination. You are learning wisdom.
You are gaining experience and that will
only cause the light to grow. Okay. So
even though going back to the story of
Eve and my dog, even though I'm hurting
myself,
okay, I am using my tremendous
imagination in order to come up with
this plan in order to redeem my
daughter. And because of this
imagination, I'm developing wisdom and
this light in me grows
stronger. Right? So that's the purpose
of life. The purpose of life is to
celebrate God by celebrating God in you.
By loving someone else so wholeheartedly
that your imagination, your wisdom grows
and grows so that your soul becomes
eternal. When it becomes eternal, it
will always be resurrected in the world
and your soul will remember the love
inside you and it will continue to grow
and grow. Okay, this is why God created
us because if God if you are perfect,
okay, if you are perfect, you are
incapable of imagination by definition,
right? Because you can make you can make
no mistakes because we are we are the
dual nature. We are both body and soul.
We can make mistakes. We can ear. And in
this process, we develop we develop
experience and wisdom which allows us to
love and to have imagination and to have
wisdom. Right?
All right. So, let me use an everyday
example that you've experienced in order
to illustrate this point. Let's think of
think about two teachers. A teacher who
loves his or her students and a teacher
who does not love his or her students.
Okay, what's the difference? All right,
so there are three major differences.
The teacher who loves students or is
asking himself or herself, are my
students learning in my class? Are they
growing as people? Whereas another
teacher might be like, "Are my students
getting good grades?" All he or she
cares about are test scores. Right?
That's the first major difference. The
first teacher who loves you cares about
what what is happening inside
you. What the teacher who doesn't love
you only cares about pleasing parents.
Okay. Second difference is this. The
teacher who loves you are asking are my
students working hard? Okay. because
only by working hard can you
learn. The second teacher is asking
students do students like me? Okay. The
teacher wants you to write a good good
evaluation at the end of semester. Okay.
Right. And then if you write a good uh
evaluation the teacher might get a raise
or some reward. Right? And then the last
difference and this is the most
important difference is this. A good
teacher who loves you is always asking
am I growing personally and
professionally? Am I growing as a
person? All right? Because if you're
growing, then I'm growing. And if I'm
growing, then you're growing. That's the
power of love. Okay? When you love
others, you're actually loving
yourself. And that's how God designed
it. But if you're a teacher who does not
love, then you always asking how much
money am I making? That's how you
measure your success in life. Am I
making a lot of money? If if I'm making
millions of dollars a year, then that
means I'm the I'm the best teacher in
China. Okay? But a really good teacher
who's capable of love, who loves
teaching and who loves his or her
students is always asking, "Am I
growing?" Because if I'm growing, then I
know my students are
growing.
Okay. So that's so that's what Dante is
saying here about
love. Meaning that we have the
intuition, we have the power to know
true for ourselves because God made us
made us this way.
Okay. So, um, something I want you to
remember from this class is the Italian
Renaissance was really just another it's
it's reimagining the Greek civilization.
Okay. And as and these are the two major
periods of tremendous creativity in
Western Europe. Right? So let's look at
the similarities to understand how
creativity happens in civilization.
Okay. So the first similarity is
um classical Greece had open cooperative
competition. Okay. So ideas could flow
freely. That's the first major
similarity. Second major similarity
is in classical Greece they transition
from linear B which is very complicated
um idographic language to the alphabet.
Okay. The alphabet just transcribes the
written the spoken word into the written
word. This allows for massive literacy
and the transfusion of knowledge in
Greece. And the idea here is if you're
truly to be a creative society, you must
be egalitarian. You must allow anyone to
learn, everyone to express his or her um
ideas, which is what the Renaissance
did. Okay. Um the Italian Renaissance
was supported by the fact that they
transitioned from Latin to the
vernacular to spoken language. It was
Dante who allowed this transition to
happen. Okay. Dante purposefully chose
not to write in Latin even though Latin
was the official language of the
intellectual class in Europe at this
time. He purposely chose to write in
Tuskin which is a local language. And
because he did that he made Tuskin first
of all the official language of Italy.
They still speak it today. But it also
makes divine comedy accessible to common
people which was the intention.
Okay. And the third similarity and this
is most important is the perfect storm
of factors don't really
matter unless you have a great poet, a
great thinker, a great intellectual to
create the spark to ignite your
civilization. Okay. So in Greece they
had Homer and we we today we can think
of Homer as the father of
civilization. In in the Italian
Renaissance you had Dante. You can think
of him as the father of modernity. The
values that he creates, the values that
he expresses in divine comedy will
become the basis for modernity.
Especially the idea of individuality of
humanism.
Right? What is individual? An individual
is someone who celebrates himself and
pursues his or her curiosity to explore
the world and in this process create
goodness in the world to create truth
and beauty. This is the idea that will
underpin the renaissance and which still
underpins western modernity uh today.
Okay. So that is my argument to you.
Okay. Great.
So um the ultimate message, the ultimate
secret of the universe that I want you
to remember, okay? And both Homer and
Dante express this in the poetry is
this. Love is the unifying force of the
universe. Okay? Love is God. God is
love. It's what unites everyone. Okay?
By loving someone else, you can become
that person. That that person can become
you. And the imagination is the
animating force. Okay. What gives life
to the world is not God but our
imagination. By imagining the world, the
world becomes alive. So the greater our
imagination, the more alive our
imagination becomes. And this idea is
most visually expressed in the painting
the creation of Adam by
Michelangelo. Okay, this is Michelangelo
um the creation of Adam. And so this
goes back to the story of how God
created Adam. Uh God created um Adam out
of dust and he breathed the essence of
life into Adam. Okay. Now there are two
ways of looking at this painting. Okay.
There are two ways of understanding the
title the creation of Adam. You can
first understand it in the typical way
which is that God created Adam and that
they are equals. Okay. You can see that
these two worlds the Adam and God
they're almost equal. We are equal to
God. But then you can change perspective
and you can say the creation of Adam
really means God is Adam's
creation. God is what we created from
our imagination. All right? Now you can
see God
um is surrounded by his angels. Okay?
But you take them away and what do you
have behind them guys? This is a picture
of the human
brain. Right? Do you see this? Okay.
This is a stem. Okay. And this is the
human brain. Okay. You take them away
and hidden behind is the human brain.
Right? Which means what? Which means
that God is an emanation from our
imagination. Okay? Not the true God. The
true God is like light itself, right?
Love itself. Okay? But this God has
given us the capacity to imagine. So
we've imagined another god to um take
place of the real god. Okay, do you
understand? So the real god is the human
imagination, the human brain, the human
mind. That's what gives life to the
universe. Okay, so this if you think
about it, it is a radical revolution in
human intellectual
history. Do you know where this painting
is? This painting is on the top of
something called the Cine Chapel in the
Vatican. It's at the very heart of the
Catholic Church. So what Dunning has
been able to do is destroy an empire
peacefully through the power of poetry,
through subtlety, through the power of
love. Don was able to influence
Michelangelo who was able to take his
ideas and then plant his ideas within
the very heart of the Catholic Church
and thus reinvent the Catholic Church.
That is the power of love. That is the
power of the
imagination.
Right.
Great. Okay. Any
questions? Okay. So think of some
questions. Um next class we will do the
Protestant Reformation. Okay.